london's financial district reacted
positively to the merkel landslide
global trading markets crave stability
but some experts are advising a change
in course for the chancellor's third
term justin urchard stewart is a
political analyst for a major london
investment bank he says it's time to
loosen harsh austerity measures for
ailing eu countries
the leader of europe of course as mrs
merkel is now
effectively seen to be a steady hand to
be able to guide not only the euro but
also the rest of the eu through what's
going to be still from very difficult
times and that is a major concern in
london whether merkel can steer the euro
back to stability the future of europe
is depending on it
the markets are expecting the german
economy to carry on doing exactly what
it has been doing and to continue this
process what we're interested to see in
the markets want to know is to what
extent just how far will the support
from journey to the peripheral states
continue after all in a single currency
that's what has to happen
the british press has also reacted
positively to the chancellor's landslide
victory
opinion makers are also convinced that
the euro crisis is the major challenge
facing merkel
and they believe she's up to the task
i think she's been
very strong
and someone that
you know everyone should look up to
really i think she's done a good job
she has probably a solid economic
background
i think she has probably good measured
judgment
and i think she has a strength of her
convictions she's already been tackling
the euro crisis
that needs to be developed further
and she needs to
understand britain's interests and i
think she does
britain's prime minister has also
expressed his delight at the german
election result
angela merkel supports david cameron and
his wish for reform was in brussels
that's why london views her as an ally
now britain expects strong leadership
from the german chancellor in order to
push for reforms in brussels and also to
resolve the crisis of the euro